after a loss you ever feel invisible no
mostly because people are always
extremely mean to me I was like yo I'll
never grab that ring oh my god have you
seen my stacks whoa pros only Remember
the Titans we lost to the bills and
nobody knows we exist yeah we should be
household names right Corey Davis right
there Carrie we need a makeover for the
gridiron heights homecoming dance I
heard you're looking for a culture
change well I used to play linebacker
whoa so relatable first we're gonna
touch you guys up with some
underperforming Patriots next we'll give
you a whole new look Wow
two-tone gray sleeves lastly it's all in
the attitude here we go for it on fourth
down now so we're basically the same
team that fired our coach after winning
a playoff game and a slight Rasta to
know where the Titans
I need him to beat me one more time this
year hi look at those you knees whoa
that's a true big market team above ever
seen one Wow the Rams got hot over the
summer
hi sports fans please subscribe to this
channel or not it's okay you can also
watch more episodes here but only if you
want to sorry for bothering you